let's switch gears now to Emily Blunt
another powerful woman last night she
was all suited up for the New York
screening of her film Mary Poppins
returns out tomorrow by the way I love
that ruffle Shakespeare collar now it
has been quite a year for Emily and her
husband John Krasinski they've got the
cover of The Hollywood Reporter to prove
it and as if you needed yet another
reason to love this power couple they go
do this hi guys we're Emily and John and
we're gonna go fishing for answers
once's answers our kids are watching
it's once's who's your first celebrity
crush one - a jungler probably was what
yeah I had a poster of Leonardo DiCaprio
it's just gonna come to mourn for me a
few other things you didn't know about
the pair named Hollywood's couple of the
year when they met Emily had never seen
John in the office right now it's just
awkward John admits he definitely
married up and neither one is the
jealous type if you went in the
entertainment industry what would you be
doing I would be renovating houses I
would be an English teacher that's what
I was gonna do before all this - Jack
Ryan
oh he's a hero guys done Mary Poppins
herself takes a five-month break between
roles but when it came to working with
John on a quiet place she says I broke
the rule for him and him alone
you're a bit groggy er than I am in the
morning what is that balloony - no just
edit yourself you lazy I think nothing I
would say I'm a morning person right
yeah I mean you like the nightlife you
like to be
[Music]
[Applause]